مرحبا عاد مسلسل الموت هذا العام بجزء
الثالث وعلى مقياس الجماهيري لم يستطع
العمل ان يحظى بنفس التفاعل اللي حدا به
خلال الموسمين السابقين على مواقع التواصل
طبعا مع عوده البطلتين ماجي بوغصن ودانيلا
رحمه من الموت وغياب عدد من اهم ابطال
للعمل سابقا ابرزهم باسم مسلسل للموت
وكاريكتور سحر كم مصري اعطاني كتير اعطاني
كتير على الصعيد المهني وعلى الصعيد
الشخصي انا هيدي الشخصيه حبيتها وتعلمت
منها القوه تعلمت منها كتير وعلى الصعيد
المهني حتني بمحل
اعلى يمكن من المحل خطوط خطوات لقدام في
كان منافس شرس للموت وصل للعالميه حتى عم
يترجم عم يتدبلج وعم يترجم لعده لغات وعم
ينحدر بكل دول العالم وهذا الشيء بيكبر
القلب صراحه تاتي احداث مسلسل للموت للجزء
الثالث في رمضان اللي تكمل احداث الجزئين
السابقين في اطار متصل ومنفصل في ذات
الوقت حيث يشارك في الجزء الثالث الشخصيات
جديده باحداث دراميه مثيره عفتنا بمحل في
تنوع كثير كبير في شخصيات كثير جديده
وشخصيات مش بس فايتين هيك يعني مش شخصيات
بتمرق مرور الكرام لا في شخصيات عن جد
فعلا حتعلم هالسنه اللي مكتوب كتير حلو
التصوير والانتاج
والتونس رحنا على تونس وصورنا
بتوينز مشاهد رائعه كل العوامل هيك ثقيله
هالسنه هي دراما عربيه فيها اكثر من جنسيه
هي بالنسبه لالنا انا بعتبرها مكسب لان
انا بتعلم من غيره وغيره بتعلم مني فهيدا
الاختلاط
هو اللي بخليك انت يقينا عندك
نضج لانك انت عم تشوف الاخر والاخر عم
بيشوفك العمل هو بسبب جزئيه السابقين
وجماهيريه ابطاله استطاع الحفاظ على عدد
كبير من جمهوره بالاضافه لفئه جديده فماذا
قال الجمهور للموت عن هذا الجزء تحديدا
[موسيقى]
الحياه مثل البيانو
قد ما تاخدي منها
بعد ما بتعرفي تلعبي
[تصفيق]